this is the larva of a botfly erupting
out of human skin
there are several species of botfly that
parasitize a range of mammals they are i
want to tell you
horrible
the female bot flight that targets
horses lays her eggs on the hot horse
flicks the area it picks up the eggs
which hatch into larvae and attached to
its stomach here's animation of another
botfly that tackles a mosquito
mid-flight and attaches her eggs to the
insect's belly
when the mosquito feeds on a human
body heat triggers the eggs to hatch
into larvae
which burrow into the wound
but it pokes its rump out of your skin
so it can poop you can use tweezers to
yank the bottle out but that'll be
uncomfortable because it's covered in
spines that anchor in your flesh
but if you let it develop for three
months or so it'll back out on its own
ideally it'll drop into the soil and
grow into an adult starting the process
all over again